hello there reject nation it's Greg Alba
here my name's John John have you ever
cracked your nuts ha ha ha that's what
we say when we talk about the Nutcracker
I came up with that joke no one else has
ever said it before me Winter's Bone ah
the ever bone the winter from Disney's
The Nutcracker in the four realms oh boy
more more expansions on the Nutcracker
this was bought from Fox I believe
already just taking all their material
we just started also wanted to say thank
you to the real reject sponsor we've
passed 2200 followers on Stardust
download the app and follow us first
trying to get to 2,300
screw scusi whoa
[Music]
we're gonnna free mana time mystery
expectations
[Music]
and also very famous the heads away from
oh this is a little different
gnarnia it is Narnia
[Music]
what the heck here Knightley
[Music]
it's also evaluation
hello hello I'm Aaron
[Music]
whoa
so does Disney have the same production
designer and cinematographer for all
their movies now this looks like Alice
in Wonderland and it looked like a
wrinkle in time and all the other live
adaptation Disney movies all them but
this wave of a very garish very high
gloss the colors and the production
design everything looks like yeah this
looks like a live-action Disney movie
they have a look now like a very
specific look yeah
can't help but think of like the Alice
in Wonderland movies when you're looking
at this one I yeah looks straight out of
it if you show me if you show me stills
of this and said this is the C the third
Alice in Wonderland movie I would think
that's it I don't think I would like
there's a lot of this I think has its
own kind of vibe to the trailer where
Helen Mirren shows up and on yeah it
definitely feels like an elephant yeah
they feel like they're in Wonderland
half of me thinks this this has the
potential to be really cool and I like
that you're seeing at least moments of
actual what looks like real ballet and
an orchestra like I don't know how as
guys I think you'll like it's gonna be a
scene or two maybe their musical numbers
will both feature ballet and that might
be a unique thing they do have you ever
seen the Nutcracker play yeah I've seen
the belly it comes to the ballet a
couple times - yeah I'm not against an
adaptation like this they've sure got
the money and means to do it always
gonna be kind of worried that this kind
of thing is gonna turn out to be you
know pretty good yeah pretty good not as
great as the original it doesn't really
do much to make it like as memorable as
that so I've seen like a cartoon or two
growing up I went to the ballet when I
was younger honestly I'm not a big fan
of the ballet mm-hmm it's special if you
really love ballet I only went because I
had a crush on the girl who was playing
the main girl I knew her at the time
this is like 13 years ago she was good
the play itself I was like I can do
without that I can do without the play
but if I'm gonna watch a live-action
movie I would like to see at least some
of that in fuse there's something about
it where I hate to just sound like I'm
being completely negative about it cuz
because I feel like at the end of the
day how I feel with a lot of live-action
Disney movies is that you really walk
out going yeah I really enjoyed it
actually
I get the strong impression that when I
walk out of this I'm gonna end up saying
I really enjoyed this film it just
doesn't look exactly as special as the
trailer is trying to make me feel like
it's special I've seen some of these
other movies and part of it is I don't
want it to turn out to be just kind of
middling and you haven't seen a wrinkle
in time yet sure looks like that too but
you haven't seen Beauty and the Beast
like I remember but I don't like adore
that movie Alice in Wonderland does have
that quality where it does at its core
at its soul yeah feels kind of half
halfway this is a classic piece I really
hope that they deliver the soul and it
doesn't get bogged down there's bad
warning signs from just a little thing
we read on IMDB this film is directed by
lasse hallström who is the director of a
dog's purpose and show haha and then it
says reshoots by Joe Johnston who did
Captain America the First Avenger he's
doing Chronicles of Narnia it's kind of
ironic that he's doing Chronicles of
Narnia and then there's imagery here and
plot point yeah you're thinking this is
Chronicles a Narnia you know yeah I mean
it's never a really good sign when you
get another really well established
director to come in and do the reshoots
on your movie you know it's like it's
weird to see reshoots just as a credit
ya for this movie to which I think adds
a little bit of worry too to the process
of it all I mean don't get me wrong
though despite it looking like these
other films it still looks great
it just feels incredibly familiar and
that's why I feel like the epicness of
it I'm not quite feeling because the
specialty feels a little bit clouded by
familiarity he's beloved adaptations
that they're doing right now
our hit and miss in terms of soul and
that's a big thing for the Nutcracker I
also don't know exactly what you know
this is called the Nutcracker in the
four realms so it seems like they're
doing that thing also where they're
gonna take it beyond I think they're
trying to make it franchise yeah and so
that also worries me about this you know
I feel like it might get in the way of
what it is
so like half of me is really excited to
see this come to life and half of me is
like oh god please I'm pretty sure this
girl played the daughter of Bella and
yeah you right now play the daughter of
Bella and Edward in Twilight at the same
time though it's another movie where you
have a child actor in the lead who not a
lot of people really know who's
surrounded by much bigger adult actors
who aren't gonna be as significant or
have as much screen time as the there
they are here they are to get some yeah
shift your anticipate yeah this trend in
movies is like a weird one to me and
it's always just like it's a
case-by-case like some of them gonna
nail it and some of them are Hollywood's
a nossa doesn't matter if I my negative
skepticism about it because this is a
nutcracker movie from Disney coming out
December 2018 it's gonna make a crap ton
of money no matter what
he's gonna get what they want from me in
the end yeah even if it gets a low score
on Tomatoes it's still gonna make a lot
of money yeah I don't know it's weird
weirdly enough I have a lot of hope for
this or I would like I would like it to
be great I was it's not just another one
of their live adaptations of one of
their princess stories or something like
that like it's totally within Disney's
wheelhouse but it's also a chance to
really explore on that yeah because if
it was just the straight adaptation of
the ballet story cuz you're talking
about the Disney classic princess
comparison yeah here you have a chance
to this thrown a lot more dialogue let's
expand the world so maybe they do have
something on their hands it's greater
than what I'm initially getting I'll
probably end up seeing it cuz it might
not be a lot of other Christmas movies
to watch next year I think it's a great
like I love the idea of having a
Nutcracker movie to look forward to for
Christmas
yes you know it's the it's the cynicism
of having done this a few times like I
don't know if it's gonna be as
what I hope it wouldn't be it's amazing
just the images in the trailer look
amazing look good alright guys well you
can subscribe to the real rejects please
click that notification bell and you can
follow us on the Stardust app download
it follow us first link in description
box and check us out on patreon become a
patron oject today it's like a second
youtube channel go there to find out
what we mean haha